- Certaines prisons provinciales
au Canada, comme celle
de Rivière-des-Prairies
à Montréal, n'abritent ss
que des criminels.
On y retrouve aussi
des migrants, détenus pour des
raisons administratives liées
à leur dossier imimmigration.
- Je trouve ça terrible.
- Cette avocate représente
des migrants incarcérés.
Me CHANTAL IANNICIELLO, avocate
en droit dl'l'immigration
- Ils sont menottés aux mains,
aux pieds. Ils ont vraiment des
conditions comme des personnes
qui sont là au niveau pénal,
imiminel, il n'y a pas
de différence.
- C'est ce qu'a vécu celui qu'on
va appeler Alex pour des raisons
de sécurité. Ce demandeur
d'asile débouté a accepté
de se confier à micro fermé.
Il dit avoir subi plusieurs
fouilles à nu à la prison
de Rivière-des-Prairies,
avant d'être renvoyé dans
son pays d'Europe de l'Est,
où nous l'avons joint.
Alex, qui souffrait de problèmes
de santé mentale, a passé six
mois derrière les barreaux,
même s'il n'était accusé d'aucun
crime. Selon un document de
la Commission de l'immigration,
Alex a été détenu en isolement
"dans une cellule, très très
petite (...) i n n'y a pas de
toilette dans la cellule,
il y a un trou dans le sol."
- Moi, j'ai des clients
qui m'appellent en pleuran
en me disant : "Qu'est-ce que
je fais ici? Comment je vais
m'en sortir"?
- L'emprisonnement de migrants
pour des raisons dmmmmigration
contrevient au droit
international selon de nombreux
avocats et experts des droits
de la personne.
Pourtant, eiriron 2000 migrants
sont incarcérés, chaque année,
dans des prisons provinciales
un peu partout au Canada,
y compris au Québec.
FRANCE-ISABELLE LANGLOIS, dg,
Aministie inter. Canada franco.
- On demande aux provinces
de résilier ces ententes-là.
- Amnistie internationale dirige
la campagne "Bienvenue
au Canada" qui demande
aux provinces de mettre fin
à leur contrat avec l'Agence
des services frontaliers pour
l'emprisonnement de migrants.
Récemment, la Colombie-
Britannique et la Nouvelle-
Écosse ont décidé de résilier
leurs ententes. Mais le Québec,
l'Ontario, le Nouveau-Brunswick,
l'Alberta et la Saskatchewan
les maintiennent pour l'instant.
- C'est extrêmement choquant.
C'est même outrageant que l'on
puisse traiter des êtres humains
de cette façon-là, dans un pays
comme le Canada.
- Pour sa part, l'Agence
des services frontaliers
dit qu'elle utilise les prisons
provinciales en dernier recours
seulement.
Ici Brigitte Bureau,
Radio-Canada, Montréa